would you agree that there's not a whole
lot of overlap
in the style of comedy that you present
as opposed to what conan o'brien
presents i mean i think we're exactly
the same
um if he ever retires there's just like
this knack for
example in the wings
[Music]
a lot of work goes into a short late
night stand-up set join me
jp buck as i spotlight the comedians who
came up with some of my favorite coin
sets
this is the setup please welcome back to
the show
very funny jenna friedman
[Music]
your first set focused on i mean it was
it was sexual assault
and took on nazis yeah and i would
actually say
i'd say that this one was even tougher
to pull off
this one was a lot tougher to pull off
weirdly enough
yes um i think the last one it was a
little it started off a little delicate
i'm actually half man
on my dad's side so
with this one the subject matter is so
morbid
and i couldn't even imagine
it ever going on late night but i think
you were like let's
try it i think as female comics it's
such like a
we're all so like what do we wear how do
we dress how do we look
cool but not intimidating and how do we
look likeable but not like schlubby
all these dumb things that take up space
my only regret i wish i had worn like a
pastel
color shirt or just something a little
softer i feel like
wearing black talking about murder just
like a like there's a lot
the hair stylist was so nice and she
like
put my hair back because i had it in
just like a ponytail and she was like
don't tuck your don't do this because
it'll look weird and the first thing
like i did just out of nerves
it's so dumb i'm sorry i'm talking about
that but that was what i was thinking
about
as i'm like delivering that about
misogyny and murder i'm like
what does my hair look like
hi it's so nice to be here uh the news
is
pretty depressing lately so to lighten
the mood i've started watching
true crime you've all
seen making a murderer if you haven't
it's a documentary about how a woman's
death
made so much money for netflix
and then the podcasts their serial my
favorite murder
missing and murdered up and vanished
whining crime white white and true crime
true crime brewery true crime all the
time what the crime
crime town prime junkie cold case killer
instincts to live and die in l.a someone
knows something
man in the window body in the moor
southern fried true crime drunk women
solving crime which i'm actually on
pretty cool uh
these are just a couple this american
death uh
doesn't exist yet but that's going to be
my retirement plan
how long could you have actually made
that joke at the time i had like a whole
page back
front and back of just different
podcasts i had done it you know in
different con i did it in edinburgh and
so it's just like the timing is slightly
different and every crowd is slightly
different so
and then there are some podcasts like um
southern fried true crime which is just
a funny
phrase so it's like but the timing
always
was different depending on the crowd of
when to get out of it
and whatnot but yeah i mean i think i
could have done a five minute set
which just goes to prove your point
i didn't realize how obsessed america
was with dead
white women in particular until it
occurred to me that ted bundy has
two netflix specials and yeah i'm
jealous
i don't know if you've seen the ted
bundy tapes i keep wanting to call them
the ted bundy mix tapes something about
the graphic design it's just so 70s so
retro it almost
it's like they want to make you
nostalgic for an era when men could just
murder women and get away with
it because there was no google earth and
then
tend to do that sometimes where you you
throw out your line
and then quickly move on and almost
don't allow them to laugh
is that is that something that you do on
purpose is that like a conscious
decision i think being a female in
comedy for 15 years
you just can't ever expect the audience
to be rooting for you
so i think or maybe just my own personal
experience i pad it with so many jokes
that i just i'm like okay laughter don't
laugh i don't care i'm going i'm still
going
like you don't like you know i could
never just walk on stage
and people will be like yeah you know
like it's very def it's like defensive
comedy the scripted movie on netflix
starring zac efron
written and directed by men where they
made the craziest person in that movie
carol anne boone
the woman who dated ted bundy while he
was in prison
they made carol look so much crazier
than a man
who murdered 30 people
and i was watching that thinking carol
ann is not crazy
she's just a woman dating in her 30s
carol anne's crazy carol anne's crazy
really what does that say about all the
men outside of prison she would have
dated but ted bundy was nicer to her
there's a lot there and i really love
that i just heard my friend ruth
laugh
[Laughter]
i see where your focus is my focus is
not on the content because i sit with
the content for so
long and my focus on the content for
like
six months or however long it takes you
to write this
chunk that when it's time to perform the
last thing you
you're an auto pilot carol anne care
bear
just wanted to meet a guy who wasn't
going to ghost her after she slept with
him
it's hard to go someone from jail
unless you're jeff epstein
it's not like he killed himself you guys
backstage before the show you still were
tinkering with the wording of that joke
i mean i wrote that epstein tag like
five minutes before i went on
stage remember i was like is this funny
which i want to say this is a compliment
my favorite thing about this set is that
tag
it really is and it rarely i mean tags
are supposed to be disposable and thrown
and easy to throw away and that tag is
really for me what makes this it's a
cherry on top of this set
the garage i mean how i mean rarely do
you want to get groans from an audience
but come on i gotta say that's gotta be
pretty i think groans are honestly
we could get into it but i think groans
are cooler than laughs because
especially when you do like club comedy
for a long time there's a rhythm and a
formula to getting laughs if you can
invoke invoke evoke i don't know another
another kind of visceral reaction from
people
i love grounds i'll take a groan because
that means they're still with you for
the most part they're just
uncomfortable which is a get which is
really
why i do what i do the docu-series
was even worse because there was all
this archival footage
of ted bundy in the courtroom with all
the police officers and ted was just
killing it
that's that's comedian slang for
slaughtering
he murdered in that courtroom he
basically slayed he had all the cops
just doubled over in
stitches laughing at not even jokes
and the lights were on and his audience
was giving him way more love than
you guys are giving me for this bit
i love that that's pre-planned because
you know what's
how they're gonna receive this because i
know that every audience i didn't set
for
freaked out and and also this set was
like
in my our show miscarriage of justice
and it was like
towards the end so i was i'd never done
this set just cold
like yeah you don't tell me hear this
like i'd never come back
if ted bundy were alive today he'd be on
his third netflix special
it would be his apology tour and he'd be
traveling around the country being like
when my friends and i realized it was
wrong to kill women
we felt so bad about it
you and i know what music comes next
forgetting the person i'm even teasing
lightly it is crazy to me like all the
kind of
me too people who get like apology tours
and i just kind of wanted to
tease them about it you know um or just
and i just
i'm just saying what he said you know
but with ted bundy i didn't appreciate
how the cops painted ted bundy as a
criminal mastermind
he wasn't a criminal mastermind he was
white
and they weren't looking for him
i'm not saying cops are racist just that
maybe cops are as
racist as comedians are funny
not all comedians are funny
but if someone's like i'm a comedian
you're like oh you're probably pretty
funny
[Applause]
where you just wait and you're like can
you guys make the connection don't have
to do it for you
they made it i mean it's so it's it's
also crazy to see that
joke in this moment just like ah
ted bundy also not an evil genius here's
how i know ted bundy wasn't that smart
he was a republican politician in utah
as he started murdering women and if he
were really ahead of the curve
he would have just stayed the course of
politics
risen to the top and then killed so many
more women with his policies
picture a version of the movie sliding
doors but ted bundy actually made the
train and then he's
ted cruz thank you guys so much have a
good night
that whole set was really fun because i
knew it was material i was really proud
of
it was something that i thought was like
very much in the
zeitgeist like i'm so glad that we got
to do this
put the set out there at that time
because now it's almost like a cliche
with the
true crime thing but i think that was
like the perfect moment to really just
like talk about it i was really
impressed how you were able to pull this
off
and i do want to just like thank you
again because both of my late-night sets
again i've been doing stand-up for about
15 years the only
time i've really had my late like my
sets on tv
are because of you and this is what i do
performing to like crickets and groans
all the time and you know it's become
like my thing
and i'm into it but i just want to thank
you
so much because i mean i started in late
night as a writer and i remember like
what i could and couldn't get on just in
terms of jokes out of like
letterman's mouth and i just never even
thought that like
late night doing a five minute set on
late night would even
be something i would ever like be able
to do with the type of comedy that i do
so to your credit and not just me like
all the comics that you book
i think are really cool and i don't i
don't see a lot of them in other places
i mean until they're on your show and
then other people hook into it but you
do take chances and risks
on comedians i do get emotional
sometimes
watching comics perform on stage begin
seeing how well it can go
it's the most fun and thank you so much
for taking a chance on an unknown kid